[Music]
Red Dead Redemption too is crammed with
things to do you can explore the vast
American wilderness and enjoy the many
scenic vistas it presents hunt animals
to provide for your friends or Rob
trains to well provide for your friends
in a less wholesome way for the most
part Red Dead Redemption 2 explains the
majority of its gameplay systems but
since its massive some of the
information is told out over the course
of multiple hours so you may find
yourself asking questions the game isn't
ready to answer yet to help you hit the
ground running we've put together a few
tips that are handy to know from the
outset these are all spoiler free so
you're in no danger of hearing about
that moment where Red Dead Redemption to
get surprisingly in depth of information
on the health and well-being of its main
character Arthur Morgan and to really
make the most of this information you
should head into the player menu in the
pause screen and select Arthur you'll be
presented with information cards that
clue you into the state of your health
stamina and Deadeye cores which dictate
how quickly each of these attributes
regenerates to guarantee you're
operating at peak performance you'll
need to maintain your cause by eating
resting and generally keeping Arthur in
good shape
you also get information on the actual
numerical percentage of how much of the
core you have remaining temperature and
weight impact stats for health and
stamina respectively so if you're
layering up in the heat or walking
around in the chillier parts of the
world as if it's a warm summer's day
you'll see Arthur's health drain faster
all outlaws are beautiful in our eyes
but if you have a specific playstyle in
mind it's important to watch your way
and manage it to suit you
hunting is a crucial part of Red Dead
Redemption tooth it brings in resources
for you and the rest of your gang to
survival but also lets you build a
deeper connection with the world around
you through study and observation when
you come across an animal to hunt don't
just go yosemite sam on it instead be
more elmer fudd and take it slow be sure
to use the study prompt as you'll get an
entry in the animal section of the
compendium that tells you a little more
about it this includes details on how
they behave the best weapons to use to
bring them down cleanly and thus
increase their value and what they can
be used for early in Red Dead Redemption
- you're taken out on a hunt and given a
run-through of how it works it's all
fairly simple but there are two main
tricks that help considerably the first
is masking your own scent
pressing the analog sticks to activate
Eagle Eye and you'll see an aura
emanating off you that's your own body
funk don't be ashamed
you're a rough-and-ready outlaw living
off the land and farting into the winds
whenever it sees you it's the good life
you'll need to make sure those wisps of
Bo aren't being carried towards the
animal as they're super judgement all of
our odors and will bolt if you're out on
a tricky hunt we recommend heading to a
vendor first as they'll usually sell you
an item to mask your smell or you can
craft one yourself also hit the baths
regularly there's a limit to how much
you can smell like sun-baked horse poop
the other tip is to attract the
attention of an animal by locking onto
them and then pressing square on the ps4
or exon the Xbox one this causes the
animal to raise its head and leaves it
in the perfect position to be brought
down cleanly
we recommend trying to use a bow as
often as possible when hunting as it's
quieter and better for getting clean
kills don't forget to give your pelts to
pearson back at the camp
one of the trappers that appears they
will hold on to them for you to come
back later and use for crafting
a certain point in the game you complete
a mission and meet offense no we're not
talking about a wooden partition
typically used to enclose outside areas
and made of Post connected by either
boards rails or wires we're talking
about the criminal variety of offense
these folk will buy stolen goods from
you which is handy if you've just
Fivefinger discount at a carriage or
horses however they'll also more than
happily take small ticket items off your
hands and say if you're the robbing and
heist ink type fences will be your best
buddies however if you're fresh off
committing a crime and have a bounty on
you you'll first need to pay that off at
the post office as fences boldchat to
you otherwise the basics of shooting in
Red Dead Redemption - are familiar
simple and intuitive however your gun
has more uses than just filling falk
with lead in fact it can also be used to
get what you want out of a person
without killing them
the thundering clap of gunfire has a way
of persuading people to be more
compliant if you take out your gun hold
the aim button and then press up on the
directional pad Arthur will point his
gun into the air when you fire you may
find people are a little more deterred
from acting out while many will usually
comply for fear of losing their lives
others may ignore you you can usually
tell when it's going to work based on
the demeanor of another person the
Cowardly types tend to stop dead in
their tracks but if you're robbing
someone and they have a defiant attitude
you may be out of luck nevertheless it's
worth a shot into the sky for those are
after our gun focus tip that's useful in
combat hit the square or the X button
while aiming to execute a dolphin dive
the game has a cover system to keep you
safe when bullets are flying by the dive
is a handy way of minimizing risk when
moving from point to point
for those who enjoy exploring the nooks
and crannies of far-off virtual lands
Red Dead Redemption tube provides plenty
to uncover one of the most immersive
ways to experience it all is to turn off
the in-game map and rely on your own
sense of direction and navigational
skills to get around if you hold down on
the directional pad and opt for turning
off the mini-map
characters that you ride with will be
more forthcoming with directions which
makes for a more natural and authentic
form of discovery if you find yourself
struggling however you can always just
tap down again to briefly bring up the
map to get your bearings while you're
out and about
keep your eyes peeled for smoke in the
sky because where there's smoke there's
usually a campfire and this more often
than not will either lead to a side
mission or a memorable random encounter
similarly listen for things happening in
your environment as you may hear someone
sharing for help or beckoning you to
come over as you pass by sometimes it's
easier to just use public transport to
get where you need to and to make use of
fast travel you can hop on a taxi coach
or a train these are usually only
available in towns but if you upgrade
Duchess quarters in the camp you can
then also purchase a map for Arthur that
allows him to return to previously
visited locations
money makes a word go round and you'll
need to keep a constant influx of cash
to get by in Red Dead Redemption 2 while
exploring the world and doing missions
it's common to come upon abandoned camps
with lots of items up for picking
sometimes you'll have to walk up to the
individual items and snatch them up but
you may also stumble upon a bunch of
goodies in close proximity to each other
in these situations instead of tapping
the loop button simply hold it down and
author will pocket the valuables as
smoothly as one of Fagin's boys one of
the most consistent sources of cash and
goods is the bodies of your fallen
enemies naturally you'll be taking a
whole load of people and you should make
it a point of stripping them of their
valuables while you're a as with the
previous game enemies you've killed are
marked on the map with a small X so once
the battles have subsided
ensure you head over to all the corpses
and recover your spoils
as a saying we just made up right this
second goes a cowboy is only as good as
the horse he or she rides in on so
you'll want to spend time strengthening
your bond with your noble steed the
easiest way to deepen your bond with
your horse is through positive
reinforcement when you're moving at a
just check on Google to beat trot
basically a walk pressing the left
analog stick and Arthur will tell his
horse how much he values it and how it's
the best distant bravest horse around
from my experience the cool down on this
is around 14 seconds so you could
min/max hold some horse compliments to
build your bond quicker as your bond
grows your horses health and stamina
will improve you'll be able to whistle
for it from further and it will come to
you even if you're in combat it also
cross deeper water and rougher terrain
and if someone tries to steal it they'll
have a much harder time other abilities
such as rearing skid turning or stopping
and even dressage also become available
there's also some tricks to riding a
horse properly as well as best practices
if you tap the X or a buttons in time
with your horses gallops you'll reduce
the rate at which the stamina is
consumed which means you can run faster
for longer make sure to also give it
regular breaks and feed it often as the
other thing that we made up right this
second goes a healthy horse is the wind
beneath it gunslingers feet when you're
riding long distances you also have the
option to use a cinema a camera if you
set a waypoint on the map and there's a
direct line along a defined route then
switch to the cinematic camera your
horse will stay true and all you need to
do is hold the Run button down
[Music]
finally here's a quick tip that will
keep FOMO at bay make sure to do the
missions that appear as white icons
around your camp
these are usually activities that you
undertake alongside other members of the
van der Linde gang and provide some nice
characterization moments these will
disappear after well either because
they're time-sensitive or because the
narrative advancements wipe them away if
one of these pops up make sure to
prioritize them over the yellow core
missions those will always be there
waiting for you so those were a few tips
that I think will be handy in making you
the best outlaw you can be if you've got
your own let us know in the comments
below or come and find me on Twitter at
2 more H if you're after more Red Dead
Redemption 2 coverage make sure to watch
quick-draw our weekly Show focus
entirely on the game our YouTube channel
also has a few other spoiler free guides
for you to check out to see you soon
partners
[Music]
you